Jason Priestley claims he punched Harvey
Weinstein in the face at a party in 1995
on Friday the Beverly Hills 90210 star
recounted the alleged incident that he
says occurred at a Golden Globes party
hosted by Miramax accompany the producer
co-founded Priestley tweeted quote
Harvey told me I had to leave I was
leaving when he grabbed me by the arm
and said what are you doing I said you
told me to leave I'm leaving I didn't
say you had to leave he replied that's
when the 48 year old says things got
heated he then grabs me tighter and says
why don't we go outside and talk about
this that was all I needed to hear
Priestley claims he hid Weinstein and
was escorted out of the party the actor
recalled his story after actress Tara
Strong tweeted that Weinstein might have
tried to derail his career the same way
he allegedly did with Mira Sorvino and
Ashley Judd director Peter Jackson
recently told the online publication
stuff that Weinstein attempted to
prevent the actresses from starring in
his Lord of the Rings franchise in a
statement to ET Weinstein spokesperson
denied ever blacklisting Judd or Sorvino
who he had previously worked with quote
mr. Weinstein continues to admire mr.
Jackson for his creative genius but he
firmly denies these accusations Sorvino
and Judd are two of at least 50 women
who have accused the former studio head
of sexual assault and harassment he has
denied taking part in non-consensual sex
[Music]
you